what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here
for another day on uncle joey's joint
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen to me
the nh nhl season is underway and
draftkings has an unbelievable offer to
celebrate the greatest sport on ice new
customers can bet one dollar on any nhl
game and win a hundred dollars in free
bets and be the team score as a goal
this week florida is coming up to see
the jersey [__] devils and it's
gonna be a fun time like i said before
and i'm gonna talk about on this podcast
i'm having a great time [__] around
with draftkings they got a social
network we could meet up on there talk
about bits talk about parlays they got
casinos they got college basketball they
got pro football [__] it's happening
right now it doesn't matter if you're a
one-time clapper or a deaf deflection
however they like the lamp you win
if sportsbook isn't available in your
state yet listen i'm not worried about
it draftkings is not going to leave you
holding your dick everyone can play for
huge cash prizes all season long with
draftkings daily fantasy sports contest
draftkings is giving all new customers a
free shot at a million dollars in total
prizes with their first deposit
draftkings is safe secure reliable best
of all you can withdraw your cash
whenever the [__] you want draftkings is
the king the official sports betting
partner the nba ufc
and the nhl what the [__] are you
thinking about i had a guy hit me up on
patreon i had six winners too bad i
wasn't in vegas what the [__] happened
to draftkings go to draftkings right now
use promo code joey j-o-e-y throw down
one dollar on any nhl game and win 103
bets if either team scores a goal
this week one puck in the net gets you
with promo code joey gets you a hundred
dollars in free bets
with draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner the nhl you got
to be 21 older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania connecticut colorado
tennessee new customers only minimum
five dollar deposit with a one dollar
wager required and
only one per customer don't get [__]
cute restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
now if you got a gaming problem
call 1-800 gambler but if not
let's go to draftkings and have a good
time kick it up tonight with a
tremendous hockey game tomorrow night
you got miami and baltimore and then you
got [__] college basketball on friday
you got college football on saturday you
got the nhl you got nfl on sunday and
monday who the [__] is better than you
draftkings use promo code joey the joint
is also brought to you by
c b d lion have you ever smoked
a cbd joint
it's tremendous to see how good it feels
when it hits your lungs and it gets
distributed to your body that's what cbd
line is all about they're the kings of
cbd whether you want to do a tincture a
bath ball a cream
the vapor pen the kinesiology tape
listen to me
this is this is the company that knows
its stuff
go to
cbdline.com
read and learn about cbd cbn
cbn will put you out quicker than
anything try to get cbn on your own you
can't
that's where cbd line comes in
they are tremendous you understand me so
read
this is not no gas station attendant
giving you information this is uncle
joey via cbd lion
telling you
the advantages of how to use your cbd
what'll work for you with the gummies
work will the tape work will the cream
work i don't know
go to cbd lion read and get back to me
pressing code joey or church and get 20
off your first order
cbd lion the [__] best
now
if there's not anything else
let's get this [__] show on the
road [__]
it's wednesday we got no time to [__]
around
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to the joint it's wednesday the
10th of [__] november moving right
along thank god it's been a tremendous
[__] week in jersey so far it's been
in the 60s
hot as [__] when i hot as [__] but
warm mildly [__] tempted bright
beautiful sun shining birds are chirping
the trees are [__] you know the
leaves are falling off it's just a
beautiful time of the year i'm happy you
guys we got a great [__] podcast
today i got a guest
later on
uh thank you for everybody who uh made
comments
on the pictures i posted yesterday from
me and my five buddies
that's a great picture you know i didn't
even look at it that hard until i posted
i was like
that's a great [__] picture and for
you people that put up i put it up on
twitter and instagram and it's been
hysterical
the [__] that you guys were saying this
is the first
cool post on instagram i haven't put up
without people talking [__] and they're
saying stupid stuff i mean i know my
hair dude's [__] ridiculous
but for you people who think it was we
were coming on the changing flavors no
and i look and i know we look [__]
old in that picture didn't we we look
like [__] young men
but for you guys that don't know
everybody looked old when we were
growing up it was [__]
crazy how old we looked in that picture
that was the eighth grade
trip we took to philadelphia
the we were going to go to betsy ross's
house
where they made the flag and all this
[__] something else that's in philly
and we were going to the nutcracker
suite
it was uh
it was like it was [__] yesterday
and we had buses like i forget the name
of the university
isn't it university bus with the schools
and [__] like that i think university
boston i remember the night before
i told my mom i was going on a school
trip and she's like what are you
bringing the kids i'm like bringing the
kids i'm not bringing them [__] she goes
you better get up the [__] shop right
and buy some snacks for the kids let me
give you some cash so she gave me like
20 bucks i bought like yankee doodles
yodels
uh
what's the the yellow ones
twinkies i bought a box of twinkies i
thought i had it covered i didn't smoke
pot then i was in the [__] eighth
grade i think we smoked
at the end of that summer we started
smoking all of us but we were [__] no
i'm lying to you guys we smoked up
mckinley
yeah we smoked that mckinley we used to
smoke out of a glass
uh
out of a glass uh i don't know what you
call them it's not a pipe
it's just like a flute
with a hole in it and you put the joint
in there and you
light the joint and then you just go
like oh
deer antlers yeah something like that
like you just
i forget what it's called so we used to
go to [__] blimpy at lunchtime up in
union city we'd [__] smoke and we'd
sit on that pipe it was a little [__]
pipe and i put it in my back pocket and
while i was eating roast beef
[__] blimpy made a tremendous roast
beef sandwich
with vinegar oil oh lettuce and tomato
onions tremendous no pickle shove it up
your ass i don't need a pickle on roast
beef there's no pickle on roast beef
[__]
so uh
we used to [__] do that [__] we
smoked pot like
once a month we was we were petrified
then but i started smoking a little more
like throughout the eighth grade i think
i smoked like maybe four or five times
that whole year but once we graduated we
were puffing that summer getting ready
for freshman year but that eighth grade
picture was taken
everybody kept thinking it was the
changing flavors or the night that uh we
were driving by sound no
so we went to philadelphia we went to
betsy ross's house first we had to wait
online it was [__] cold out and [__]
we got through it and then we went to
the nutcracker suite we brought a bunch
of [__] paper clips and we broke them
in half and we all had rubber bands
so me
orlando salcedo david ruiz dominic
speciale we sat and we just shot paper
clips at the [__] people one after
the other pop pop the people who
performing there's let me tell you
something those things hurt when we were
kids they tell you don't shoot paper
clips because you're going to take
somebody's [__] eye out like they
banded at school and [__] we stayed up
all night breaking paper clips we had
rubber bands so after about 30 minutes
of shooting paper i never forget like we
kept missing our aim wasn't good you
know at the beginning our aim wasn't
good and then we got a hold of it
and there was like a 10 paperclip run we
all shot at them and there were two
principal people on the stage i don't
remember the [__] play there were two
principal people on the stage and i
remember that they were holding their
legs like ah ah and after like 10
[__] eyes the curtain dropped and the
light the house lights came on and they
[__] went out to the auditorium they
pulled this out of them we got thrown
the [__] out the teachers were mad at us
for maybe 10 minutes
i put up i posted a picture tuesday i
posted a picture monday the whole 8th
grade class
but tuesday i posted one of me anthony
balzano god rest his soul and wally
lindsay wally lindsay was a teacher i
had he was the mayor of weehawken
but he was a grammar school teacher in
north bergen why i don't [__] know i
be i felt i found out that day when the
atf came and arrested him for [__]
racketeering and murder that dude in the
picture i posted on twitter and whatever
went to prison for racketeering and
murder he was racketeering the
waterfront and weehawken selling it
without [__] i don't know the whole
story back then but he did end up doing
13 years
and i spoke to wally about maybe seven
years ago and he was very [__] proud
of me so
it all worked out you know what i'm
saying so if you get to look at the
pictures on twitter
go on twitter or my instagram mad flavor
and you'll see both pictures they're
cool pictures uh
i never saw them before
some girls sent them to me they're
getting ready to do mckinley reunions so
she sent them to me just to get me
excited i'm excited about it it's next
week
uh let's see what happens you know what
i'm saying my schedule changes
every other [__] day i got something
you know but
it works out i gotta talk to you guys
about something
and let you know what's going on um
i was [__] excited this past weekend
i really was i'm like [__] i'm gonna
be able to watch something i like like
right now i'm waiting for a couple shows
i was waiting for narcos i was waiting
for cobra kai with my daughter because
we're gonna watch that while she's off
school all that week uh christmas
holiday you know i was waiting but i was
really waiting for [__] narcos
friday thursday night i stayed up till
midnight because i thought it came out
at midnight but it didn't
three in the morning yeah came on at
three in the morning when i [__] got
up friday
i went against my own will and i tried
to watch the first episode in the
daytime like after everything was done
obviously i sat down and watched the
first episode
it was very weird
the second episode
was a little weird
finally by the third episode i started
getting what was going on and i was
still [__] confused
then the fourth sixth and the seventh
episodes picked up some momentum
and it led me
into the
eighth and ninth and tenth uh episodes
which
they were okay
the show i thought was tremendous
i thought this year's show wasn't that
[__] good like it just didn't uh
it just didn't grab you
and
the ending was kind of weak how he ended
and [__] like that
they had a couple of violent things they
threw a side story in there about a guy
who was hunting a girl killer he got
fired as a cop trust me way the [__] out
there okay
let me tell you what happens guys before
you guys lose your mind okay
when you have a popular show i.e the
sopranos miami vice
narcos
uh the one that was on amc breaking bad
anytime you have a show like that
the first two seasons of blockbuster
right [__] people talking about
everybody's talking about you you're on
tv guide you're [__] everywhere
what happens is
uh
indexes another show that that happened
to also
what happens is the first three seasons
you've got the full writing crew right
you've got the full right these are the
writers that were there from you from
day one but guess what after your show
gets hot the hotter the hardest thing to
handle
is your writers
because they all get offers for more
money
when you're on a hot show you go from
being a writer to being a head writer on
a different show or
moving up two notches like you're more
involved with that writer you're working
with the producers so every time you get
a job it's a way better job you know
what i'm saying so
like miami vice you watch miami vice
first season was mind-boggling
mind-boggling how good it was
second season men's amends
they got they found out they had a hit
show dirt season was pretty [__] good
after that miami advice fell for the
dogs cocaine
uh [__] egos
but most importantly the writing i mean
they had an episode about martians on
miami vice how do [__] martians come
into cocaine in my [__] world but
whatever so that's what happened on
[__] narcos i mean they
the writers just switched and uh
it's a [__] shame i know he's got a
couple other shows andrew baez he's got
like godfather harlem and some other
show on
stars he's a he's a great executive even
even like let me give an example
sons of anarchy great [__] show okay
sons of anarchy ends he goes over to
mayans
he's the executive producer the
showrunner the whole [__] thing of
mayans he was on it guess what he had
just done seven years on [__] sons of
anarchy
by the time he got the mayans he was
burnt out i'm talking about kurt sutter
the show runner the creator of all that
[__] of sons of anarchy he was burnt out
he ended up getting fired from his own
[__] show really yeah he's not on the
show no more he's not mines anymore it's
his show he still gets a creative credit
you know 13 14 i don't know i don't know
exactly what it is
but
no he's and that's how fast
that [__] moves around the result is
you're sitting there going wow this show
went to [__] no it didn't go to [__]
they changed their [__] writers
and that's what the [__] happens you
understand me miami vice did the same
all those shows did i don't think
breaking bad did it breaking bad held on
yeah they were pretty [__] good but
it's just some shows
that they go down the [__] tubes you
know uh
today i got my friend josh wolf on the
show
i noticed he put out a special last week
i've been me and josh moved around the
same time he came to
nashville and i moved to [__] uh
new jersey
you know when i got here me and josh are
tight very tight uh we're family tight
his family i know his brothers his
parents his babysat his kids
you know so throughout this whole
journey of us being here just because i
didn't have them on the podcast didn't
mean
we weren't jacking you know we've been
talking the whole time
bouncing ideas off each other and i'm
really happy he's at la
i think that uh
when you move to l.a sometimes you get
too dependent on your agents and the
people that are working around you and
we forget that we have to do all the
work i never forgot that i never forgot
that that you have to do all the work
and bring it to them and then they'll
never
initiate it so for you young comics
you're like i don't know what's going on
my agent yet
they'll won't initiate it you can't just
sit there and think your agent's gonna
get your [__]
you gotta keep working and eventually
you guys be in the middle
and you bring them stuff and i know
you're paying them a commission why am i
paying them if i got it guys
this is part of the business so don't
[__] feel bad about it but
you know josh and i
had been in l.a around the same time i
think he had been there about a year
before me
um
we were together from 97
to 2001 just trying to figure it out you
know and like i told him i'm gonna tell
you guys
you know we're writing the book and we
had to write this chapter a couple weeks
ago and it was the best feel good
chapter of the book so far
like it was when the you know
we can we talk about me growing up we
talk about me going to prison kidnapping
people this is completely different this
is when i get into an art
and i find friends that are like-minded
it was me ralphie
gavin you know a bunch of us six or
seven of us we were all broke
we were all going through the same thing
we're trying to find our [__] voices
we were trying to figure out what the
[__] to do and
by the looks of it man we [__] did it
you know but the best time
in my whole comedy career wasn't when i
did the chicago theater it wasn't when i
did town hall i like to think that i
really like to think that i like to
think those are the highlights of my
life
when i did the longest yard the best
time i had on my career
was when we were getting to that place
the struggle
you have to look forward to the struggle
if you don't it's not gonna work out for
you that's when most people quit
they don't like it it's it's you know
they don't like sleeping on floors
they don't like sleeping without a fan
they don't like
going to bed with a [__] empty
stomach
when you're first starting out in comedy
when you when you love comedy so [__]
much that's what you do
you starve for it you you
sacrifice your family for it you don't
want to come home your mom will call you
you found you know how many times i was
with comics and they're like man my
parents i haven't seen them in a year
they want me to come home for
thanksgiving but i'm too [__] busy
and i would look at them not having
parents i go dog run back and see your
parents and like no
i'm too [__] busy that's the love
that you have to have for comedy that's
the love that's the love you have to
have for whatever you're doing that's
the passion that you have to have if you
want to get to that place whether you're
in a band whether you play the guitar
whether you want to sing whether you
want to suck dick whatever the [__] you
want to do that's the [__] cost of it
is sacrifice
and nobody listen one thing i can look
you in the eye and tell you is that
i saw ralph he made sacrifice
i saw [__] joshua sacrifice
and i saw my sacrifices and guess what
when i saw them sacrifice things it was
i don't know it was like uh
it inspires you like this is what i got
to do
to get to that place if that's what i
got to do
i'm going to [__] do it before i
introduce josh wolfe i got to talk to
you real quick
about
betterhelp.com
listen today the joint is sponsored by
better help online therapy if you're
scared of going to therapy like i was
think about it this way okay when you
drive a car every 90 days it goes for a
[__] oil change right right well the
same thing
happens with the brain going to therapy
is routine maintenance for your mental
and your emotional wellness
it's a tune-up
you know in a year not catching fire in
the middle of the road i
never dreamed of going to therapy i
always thought i wasn't crazy i always
thought i didn't have mental health
issues
when the pandemic came and whatnot the
world started getting mental health
issues
i just got an email today from sag the
screen actors guild about uh
depression and what's going on over
there
going to therapy does not mean that
there's something wrong with you it
means that you're investing in yourself
to keep your mind healthy
better help is customized online therapy
they offer video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist you
don't have to see anybody on camera if
you don't want that it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can start communicating with your
therapist within 48 hours why invest in
everything else and not in your mind
right everybody's talking about bitcoin
you're gonna lose your [__] mind
every day i i suggest
you try it i
had some mental health issues this last
year i never had them i had some
feelings i wanted to take care of i had
some unattended issues i had to take
care of and that's exactly what i did i
had to take the blunt off my [__]
shoulders
like i said why invest in everything
else and not in your mind just for the
joint listeners what i'm gonna do this
month is give you 10 off your first
month
with betterhelp.com
diaz i work with a therapist called dana
and uh she's done great by me i mean we
talk once a week you can set up your
appointment it's easy to cancel if
you're busy and you do it at home on
your time she has nighttime appointments
daytime appointments weekend
appointments so do yourself a favor go
to betterhelp.com that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r
h-e-l-p
dot com slash joey
diaz
d-i-a-z
take control of your life go to
betterhelp.com i'm going to give you 10
off the first month when you use code
diaz betterhelp.com
online therapy that's going to rock your
[__] world i love it i do it once a
week
and you guys have seen the change of me
right now
i want to present one of my brothers to
you guys i love them to death we had a
nice [__] chat i hope you enjoy it i
hope your young comics are watching this
i want to introduce josh wolfe i'll see
[__] suckers afterwards
[Music]
what up mook
what's going on man what's happening
welcome to the [__] joint my
friend
i'm so psyched to be here how are you
doing i'm putting the pieces together
man every [__] day is a different
adventure
yeah one day at a time
what's that poster behind you the one
you gave me oh yeah bruce lee and dana
santo and [__] looking good back there i
got a mirror there you want to cover it
i don't like looking at myself in the
mirror at night you know what i'm saying
i do know what you're saying sometimes i
wake up
especially now you know
and i in my brain i wake up and i look
like i did you know 20 years ago and i
look in the mirror i'm like who's that
[__] dude you know what i mean it's
scary when somebody gives you a picture
of you
or sends you a picture and you're like
oh
that's not good
do you know joe when you when in your
brain you're like i kind of look the
same and then someone sends you a
picture from like
a while ago and you're like oh no i
don't
know i don't like it
i don't know
anything
you can lift all the weights you can
it's not good anymore i'm gonna tell you
something right now dude my skinny
little legs are not getting any bigger
those things refuse to [__] work for
doug
those [__] legs of yours just
refuse you got to put heavy [__]
squats on there like 300 400
for three
huh how long you know me now
20 years
have these legs ever gotten any bigger
than this
no
it's a [__] shame
what a shame you're gonna have a hard
time when you're 60.
you're going to have a cart and a
[__] helmet because you know you
might fall off the [__] cart and [__]
that's that scares the [__] out of me
like people's parents start to fall
when you're 55. i work on my balance
every [__] night because of that i am
so scared
ever since i fell off that [__] bike
before i moved to new jersey
i'm petrified of falling anymore
petrified that fall was horrible
in l.a i'm like i didn't break my
[__] shoulder my neck
but
i mean at our age when you fall on the
ground
some something bad is going to happen
some baskets
something bad is going to happen you
know you watch football you watch all
these guys flying through the [__]
air and hitting each other i've been
watching football this year the last two
seasons because i'm not on the road no
more i got time to sit pull up a chair
place a little [__] 25 dollar bet and
[__] like that i had the ova last night
two nights ago thank god i got beat up
this week on draftkings
that [__] beat me the [__] up
prop bets
everybody i couldn't pick a winner
saturday night for the ufc
and then sunday you saw a [__] sunday
every anybody who got upset i had them
like i had the rams i had [__] dallas
given 10
you know i had the bills
i had the bills
given 14. they lost by three they didn't
know it's like they didn't eat wings or
some [__] that week
i don't know what the [__] happened to
them
but uh
it's just uh yeah
i i had a winner on monday night and i'm
happy and i'm reevaluating my [__]
gambling after this weekend do you
remember
there was a dude i knew when we were in
seattle who parlayed the same and i
forget what three teams it was college
and he would do it
three teams remember it was like three
teams miami oklahoma florida state and
he just rode those every week every week
every week you're a winner at the end of
the season not by much you're not gonna
win a lot but you're you're in the
positive that those three you know
unless they stop covering
like last night dallas didn't cover once
i seen brett michaels
i knew not to bet [__] pittsburgh i
swear to god asked jimmy florentine we
were sitting at his house i saw brett
mike was like i hope nobody in the room
bet [__] pittsburgh last night he's
the kiss of death sure enough they
didn't [__] cover
time it's like [__] pete rose night
or one of those celebrities gonna show
up and you get all that they're
definitely gonna win tonight
[__] joe montana's there they get
killed
they always get killed
i i one thing that for me and you taught
me this
you this the saying that america is not
that smart so when you see everybody
betting on something you gotta bet the
other way you gotta bet the other way
and you're trying to deal with another
job that's what you told me you've never
seen a book you would participate and
that's what i like about yahoo
yahoo
what you do is let's say you're looking
at a game you're looking at i don't know
the cowboys against denver don't [__]
remind me i love the cowboys you know
and uh
they're giving
i don't even know what the [__] we're
talking about here i lost my train of
thought here we're talking about the the
the betting on what everybody else is
betting on right let's say they're
giving ten whatever you go to yahoo and
you click on that game because yahoo
tells you what games are up
that day
click on that and the game it'll tell
you you know first place in the eastern
conference
third place in the western conference
and then you scroll down and it'll
actually have the breakdown
the money line and the line and the
total
of what america's betting
it's pretty interesting
it's very [__] interesting what
everybody's looking at and that's what
you base your pics off of you know i'm
not greedy it's like
i was thinking about this the other
night how gambling has changed in my
life
gambling we did to make money to
actually think we were going to beat
somebody and make 8 000 and get our dick
sucked no that's not going to work that
way
i put a nickel in there i had a g in
there till this weekend
on 25 stupid bets
the world series i just bet i didn't
even bet the world series i would bet
a run to score in the first inning
and that's a smart way to go right yeah
they always hit a home run in the first
inning except for two games
they always scored you know when the
playoffs i always bet the first
run florentine used to laugh at me he
goes don't you pick a [__] side i go
nah they got all these prop bets
i don't want to sit and watch a game for
three hours to get the final result
that sucks dick and i don't want to sit
there
so i'd rather just put a prop bet and
you know where you stand at the end of
the first inning they have first five
innings they got so many [__] things
you can bet on that it's kind of fun you
know
listen you just bet in ten
there's some nights on board i play
blackjack for a quarter
i win and i'll go i'll quit when i win a
dollar
at least i'm up a dollar for the day i
did okay i made a dollar that's it
another day another dollar you make a
[__] dollar
were you the one who told me also
friday night nba home teams always as
soon as the line shifts
yeah the more points they're getting the
more money you're putting on that team
so if you like i love the celtics on
friday night the celtics and the sixers
at home
the line is up and especially like if
you put if you bet that that's celtics
from california you get a decent line
but if you call boston
to bet the celtics on a friday night
the line is definitely a half a point
to a point maybe a point and a half
bigger they do that because you live in
boston you're not going to meet toronto
you're going to bed boston so when that
line shifts two points
and it happens all the time i always
look at the tuesday you look at the
games for the week now i don't look at
them no more sunday you look at them
again
the games that you were looking at the
three games you were looking at if one
of those lines changes neither
directions you go where that line
changes
so if that line goes up you bet that
team if that line goes down you bet that
underdog
that meant they're forcing you to bet
who's your team this year in football
that you've been riding
tennessee's a sleeper
i'll tell you who won me some money
indianapolis
nobody saw them coming see now everybody
see him coming now you can't bet
football after this week i'm done with
football
that's it i'll switch it up to college
basketball
on monday nights that's great
and just bet on monday nights on college
basketball it's a [__] system but if
you fall into the system it's not going
to be fun anymore you know how many
people i know that don't watch sports
because they could caught a beating
gambling
beating like they had to get jobs they
had to borrow money from their mother
they had to pimp their wife out the
whole [__] deal because they
those people do not watch sports anymore
i don't want that bad feeling
you know i want to enjoy myself you know
so if it's 10 bucks who gives a [__]
i won't eat chinese today i'll just bet
[__] uh you know i don't do
basketball though nba's
nba and baseball will [__] kill you
for sure baseball will kill you anything
that's every day
will kill you i don't like basketball
betting it i'll watch a game when knicks
are good this year i watch them for
three minutes and i'll move the [__] on
yeah for me baseball is the hardest
because
truly on and look over the whole season
you can bet
on a team right
but on one single night look pedro
martinez lost games
right pedro in order to win on a pedro
martinez game you had to bet so much
right yeah but that dude lost two
baseballs one of those games it's not
it's not
football right 16 games you know this
team's gonna go 12 and four or whatever
the 162 games so they're gonna lose a
lot do you know what i mean and on those
any given nights it's too much of a risk
for me and especially the good teams in
baseball you've got a with a good
pitcher you gotta bet so much for even
for it to make sense you know what i
mean the ufc the night had a couple
fights that
if you bet 25 hours you won 37. it's not
worth me sweating bullets for 12 dollars
you know i don't want to sweat bullets
for 12 [__] dollars i don't mind
playing a hand the blackjack for two
dollars or you know whatever i don't
want to sweat for [__] 13 so i won't
bet it you know sometimes the odds are
shitty
with gambling i i gotta do what i like
i don't [__] play games like let's
see
i'm very serious and i take it seriously
you know like i like it i don't i
wouldn't do big because i have a
daughter yeah and i have a wife and i
have mortgage payments and i know what
happens when you start betting five ten
thousand dollars it's just
you're gonna it's listen you're gonna
lose
you're gonna lose
when you start chasing your money if i
could play the whole season on one
[__] deposit
i could care less and then do maybe
college basketball for march madness
again but i won't i won't do anything
that's every day
with gambling that's where you get
caught up that's where you die when it's
every [__] day you know
yeah those the the dudes who
chase their money like i've gotten good
at not chasing my money anymore i'll
take it i'll take an l i'll take you now
because i know next week i'm gonna try
again
but i don't lose a bet on a saturday and
chase that money throughout the weekend
anymore you i remember doing that man
cha if you lose that big bet on saturday
you chase that money the whole weekend
next thing you know you're up at four in
the morning snorting coke
waiting to get the score from hawaii
once you're watching hawaii you know
you're a [__] loser if you bet in
hawaii i gotta be honest with you i hate
saying this to people but you're a
[__] loser
if you're on if you're sitting there
waiting for hawaii to score
doing coke you know
it's not going to work out for you i
know a couple guys that lived down
[__] hawaii and they got killed i
know my brother he's [__] you know
you can't even mention hawaii in front
of him you can't even
[__] mention don ho in front of this
[__] guy because hawaii killed them
you'd be lying if i told you
i didn't watch a couple hawaii san diego
state games in my day
just [__] like
that's that last game with the latest
[__] it's a [__] nightmare
that's my rule number one if you gotta
bet miami it's time to do something
different you got to sell pencils to
blind people you got to make it work for
you you got to make believe you're blind
i was thinking about that the other day
there's no blind people no more selling
[__] pencils what a nightmare this
country has become rude
jesus even a blind guy you never see a
blind guy at walmart no more standing
out there with some pencils and [__]
talking to some blind shaking [__]
how you doing baby girl hold on i'm
gonna sell some pencils
i'll take you over to some eye glassware
it's [__] crazy
how's tennessee man i love it dude you
know i'm i feel really good
um i'm i
i should have left los angeles five
years ago
may 2015 that's when i should have left
before i saw behind the high-end rod
curtain
yeah he and i i was telling you this
earlier man but for me
it was i didn't see the gradual change
in who
i had become
there it slowly started to take a little
bit away from me and not until i got
here did i look back at who
who i've become and been like
embarrassed i was embarrassed about
the dude that i had become and the
things that i had made important in my
life you know
so had i
i took a look at that
i didn't like my behavior the last five
years across the board it worked for
then
i don't know who that dude is anymore
like
when i watch old churches a clip or
something i i have no idea who that dude
is anymore
i appreciate that [__] with all
my heart
but uh
it was weird i'm
i was thinking about our conversation
before about l.a and
i mean we had it
listen i'm writing a book josh wolfe and
one of the best chapters i wrote
was about two weeks ago about our lives
from 98 to about 2
000. you really
look at that and you see that's a movie
that was a movie that's almost famous
that's all those movies you see on cable
or on hbo about
bands and you know queen and [__] like
that what we did should be a movie
should be a tv series
and it was one of the best times of my
life and we were broke
we were [__] flat broke
some way or another we're figuring out
how to make a 10 here and a 15 there to
snort some coke
but i probably had three pair of pants
i'm not ashamed to say this today
because that was my strength you know
i didn't buy underwear because if i
bought underwear i took away from my
cocaine budget
so i had socks pants t-shirts
you know but schrader
vista
kirsan
sierra bonita
i mean we could write a [__] show
from those
two years stealing cigarettes from the
arab guy when he was pumping gas
you know going to the grill yeah going
to the sunset grill when the dude had
the [__]
the platform foot and he would swing his
leg around that's the guy don henley was
talking about you know i
i thought the sunset grill was yeah
chicks and [__] like that and it's on
the street it didn't have a sitting area
and it was two mexican chicks with an
old guy who had to pick up his leg to
[__] throw it around like if you
threw like if you throw a
curveball at him like let me get a
double cheeseburger he's like ah and
he'd have to pick up his leg and whip it
around and then with the [__]
i mean
it was just you cannot [__] believe
these stories and that's my next venture
is that you know call it five blocks
i was you know
[__] playing tennis with doug
stanhope mitch hedberg you know talking
to mitch about the arguments he would
have with nick depalo who was his
next-door neighbor he would bang on the
door
you know ralphie may cooking barbecue
[__] turkeys at six in the morning
with jay moore in the backyard and
nobody had dough
not even ralphie at that time ralph
didn't have dough
it was just a [__] uh you know what
it was joe
you know what when i one of the reasons
that i look back so fondly on it is
because
all this other [__] that you realize
is around
you're more aware of the [__] the
more successful you get because you're
more exposed to it
but at the time it was just that group
of dudes
all with the same goal
just
figuring out
this how to create and and it was all
about that dude it was like what bit are
you doing going to watch somebody wait
in line and watch them do their five
minutes and work on a bit talking about
the bit act afterwards it was so
collaborative and it was really all just
about us
and and
and and doing this doing this job that
we
really also the time dude
you look back on a fondly because there
was a strong love for what we did
we loved
getting on stage
and i'm not sure that same passion
i don't know how you maintain that for
however many years
but when i think look one of the reasons
why i've changed so much about what i do
on stage
is because i need to keep it fun for me
or else i'm gonna get bored and if i get
bored like you i'm just gonna stop
right if i get bored
i don't
i i'm not gonna do that job anymore so
i've really started to mix up
what i do on stage
and it keeps me interested
[Music]
i was never bored i think it's very
[__] exciting work
uh sitting here not going on stage
reflecting a little bit every day
journaling
i had i'm very proud of my open mic
career
most people will never say that in the
world
you know i had some ups and downs during
my open mic career but i really played
it cool
and i didn't go anywhere i didn't belong
before my time and we [__] really
worked
and you know
our common goal at that time
was just to
survive just to make it we were living
day to day what spots you got tonight
we're going to go to the coffee shop
and then swing by the improv and then
you know
i [__] loved that journey
and it all goes back to 1998. this is
the weirdest [__] thing i i went to
the riviera to do the dirty show
and i got on a southwest flight in las
vegas and i saw
slash got on the plane and i didn't say
nothing to him i had seen him at the
store a few times
we went to the riviera you know the
plane landed i went to the river i
didn't think about it again but there
was a convention at the river
some type of convention like a guitar
convention there was something going on
downstairs and i went downstairs to walk
around
and i actually saw a slash at a booth
talking to people signing pictures and
[__]
and i went over and i go hey how you
doing man he goes good and that was it i
didn't you know good to see you you know
saw you at the store yeah i was there
with chewie you know the whole [__]
thing
and i remember that that night i was
[__] bored as [__] after the show
it's a midnight show
it's like a late show in vegas 11
o'clock
and i went downstairs to smoke a joint
on the way back
i saw slash there by himself
and i go this is my chance just to ask
him some questions you know
and i went over i was broke i was lonely
i was bored
and we started talking and one thing led
to another we actually started talking
about careers and comedy and [__] and
he's like listen
you're broke right now aren't you and i
go yep
he goes yeah you're getting on stage
every night you're writing i at that
time i think i did a movie like i was in
baseball or something we were talking
about that i remember that and he goes
listen man i want you to remember
something
the best times you're gonna have are
right now when you're broke
this is the best
once it becomes a business
some people hate it
and they move on that's what happened to
axel he was telling me that that day he
goes that's when i i'm an axel
you know he just snapped he couldn't
believe he had all that success
in a rush and he just didn't appre he
didn't smell the roses
and i'm i'm really appreciative of my
open mic
like i i'm really proud that i did the
building correctly
like the bait the building the building
blocks i did them correctly for two
years i just got on stage and
improvised
you know for two years i got some
material and i would do a hybrid type of
thing improvise and do material then i
started yelling
and then i moved to la and i started
when you talk on stage in l.a they ain't
going for that [__]
it's not new york city hey where are you
from what do you do for a living
they [__] you know so that was the
end of that
and then i went through the rodney
dangerfield period and then that didn't
work and then i finally realized that i
had to tell stories
to connect with people and that's how we
got to where we were and
it's just funny that
i had a great time going to milwaukee
and chicago and zanies and
you know all these theaters and [__]
but it didn't beat the time we had in
seattle
no man you know
the the broke but sitting down at that
i forget what that 24-hour cafe was out
near where you hid in the trash can with
rico yeah the tropic that the hurricane
was it called the hurricane the
hurricane yeah the hurricane
i remember going there after open mics
and
you know in seattle i didn't have money
but i had more money than everybody else
because and i remember going there and
like we'd buy like
a pot of coffee with brody and maybe
tina and we'd sit at the tables after
open mics and just talk comedy
just for the love of the comedy and and
let me tell you when i say bored i'm
never bored on like
performing
but i like
i like to challenge myself with
something new every night because the
new things if i knew that if i know
there's something new in my act it fuels
my entire act the excitement of trying
something that i haven't done before you
know
but but that excitement back then of not
knowing dude we didn't know what to say
or what was going to be funny we just
knew that we all
shared this love for this thing
and it was really exciting man and i
gotta tell you like
i'm really glad
that
that i feel lucky that i get to start
with you and brody i feel really lucky
you guys you guys taught me a lot
because you guys had a different path in
me
i don't want to say my path was easier
but
especially early on you guys were
extreme people you know what i mean by
that
i i could step on stage and fit in
do you know
you guys had to find your b yes yes
and so i was always
fascinated by you guys because watching
you even on the way up
maneuver that like i said for me easier
the way i look
white dude i'm gonna kind of fit into
most rooms that i stand on stage
youtuber and i'm kind of
middle of the country relatable kind of
burst you guys are extra extremes
and so it was fascinating for me to
watch you guys
do the same thing i was doing but have
such a different journey like the
audience's reactions to you guys
especially when they didn't get you
was something i never had to deal with
you know
yeah especially when you were this joe
diaz when you were this guy oh this dude
this dude
the hand pumper you made some people
nervous up front for jack when you were
doing
pissed it
god damn
do you remember the very first time
yo the very first time i saw brody snap
on stage was at the underground and his
jokes were he was bombed
just
and
he
said i don't think you understand people
how hard it is for a single man to shave
his own back by himself he goes i got
trouble spots and he lifted up his shirt
and he showed the patches on his back
yo
trouble spots
i was howling but i was like in my life
i'll never have to do that
you know what i mean
it was great yeah to watch brody
especially at the store and at the
underground
i have those memories drilled listen man
i have a problem i can't remember
nothing
from
2010 on
like if you bust my balls about 2014 i
don't know nothing
between the edibles the [__] reefer
the kid god knows nothing i destroyed my
[__] memory
but i have and i have real memories of
brody like on stage at the store
and me going i don't think bro he's
gonna last
because he was having like when he first
got to la he was going up there doing
eight minutes they weren't on board and
he would just snap and that's what made
him funny you know we loved it we loved
his comics and [__] you know in the
back
but the audience he was struggling yeah
he was struggling and i respected brody
because he showed up every [__] night
he didn't give a [__]
what happened the night before he had
the right attitude
that was last night [__]
tonight's tonight okay so
it's funny that we did learn a lot from
one another i learned a lot of [__] from
me do you remember doing the [__]
industrial
that saturday like in september we had a
do a an industrial shoot where we had to
just pick up boxes and drop them off for
people like just pick them up and drop
they gave us like 75 bucks it was like
ups and all me josh and gavin did was
like pick up boxes
and like every once in a while we wave
at the camera and the guy will go don't
do that
he will [__]
and i remember going this is my first
industrial oh my god i'm on my way
like i i still remember going out i
still remember going to la
my first audition was judy brown
called me up she was booking the jenny
mccarthy show
which for you people don't know judy
brown is one of the biggest managers in
the world today sebastian
whitney [__] uh
bill what's his name not bill bird but
bert kreischer i'm really proud of judy
judy came a long way i met judy in
colorado springs when she was charging
20 bucks to take a stand-up class before
you could do the open mic there and [__]
i'm like julian yeah i'm not paying you
20 bucks
she's every time i see her she's like
you never paid me that
i'm not going to pay you that 20. in
fact you owe me 35 hours from [__]
vail
how's that but my car blew up and i left
it there and i had to call the dealer
and go remember that nice [__] car
that was there yet the engine blew where
are you i'm in the [__] i'm in vail
i'm i'm quit
i'm in manny's car dawg i [__] climb
with that many's car i was talking about
the aunt manny carter the other day when
they got towed and i tried to go down to
hollywood to get my [__] out of it and
they're like you need a registration and
i actually went home and like
got carol's registration and tried to
[__]
how many tickets were in that car
200.
that's not an exaggeration by the way i
remember seeing those tickets in the
back seat you should just take them and
throw them
i just took them and threw them in the
back and [__]
i still remember the lady would follow
me the little black lady with the she
had like a [__] cheese danish on her
head
she was spun it around the head like the
afro she was the most angriest woman in
the world i brought her flowers i sang a
michael jackson songs i would sing al
green songs i threw the whole black
catalog of love music at this sister
because she was fine too
yeah and she would get out of my face
and i remember finally one day she goes
i'm just going to keep giving you
tickets and i go
[__] it i have a stack and a
there must have been a hundred in there
she goes oh lord
you're gonna go to jail
and they didn't tell me in hollywood
doesn't they got me up in [__] the
valley
yeah they got me in the valley with that
[__] car i was in there taking a
shower i go outside to get my shorts the
car is gone i didn't bring all my
luggage with me i just took a t-shirt if
i would have brought my whole luggage
with me i wouldn't have been this
predicament today
let me tell you
the when i used to get in i remember
getting that car and looking in the back
seat and being like
you got some tickets and you're like
yeah i'm like
are you gonna pay them you're like nah
they're gonna have to come get me and
that was it
what am i gonna pay him with where what
what do you want me my good looks
the car had no brakes no
no brakes i would have to step on the f
i was like fred flintstone for real i'd
have my foot on the brake and the other
foot outside the door stopping the
[__] car i stopped dog on the 405
south i had to do it one time
the car had a tremendous cassette player
a sunroof and air conditioning
you don't know how many times i would
just park on the street
pop the seat back boom and just pop the
sunroof i still remember being on vista
and jerking off doing coke in the car
[__] jerking off and then taking
napkins and and put them outside and i
remember waking up in the morning when
the sun wakes you up and stretching and
looking down and seeing like eight
little sperm napkins and going this is
not good this is not good
i jerked off on the street i'm visiting
i would not be surprised if those sperm
napkins were still on that street right
where you left them
drive right down the block there's
probably a homeless guy wiping his face
he's just eating a subway sandwich and
he's taking my little sperm napkin and
wiping his sides like gray poupon and
[__]
yo do you remember
when that dude oh by the way
jacob wolf was at that travis scott
concert on friday
yo i forgot to tell you this
so i'm so glad i was asleep but i wake
up to a text
hey i'm all right
but [__] got real hairy
so he and his girlfriend
have bruises
circling their body from where they were
being smushed by the crowd he showed me
my man just has bruises because he was
being compressed
oh joe i forgot this story is so bananas
man
he said at one point his girlfriend
who's smaller
her feet weren't touching the ground
but she was stuck between people and
just being moved
there was she was like this
and so many people compressed she was
being moved by the crowd
and that he said
that he
he would look down and he would see
people's faces
everyone was just walking on people and
you couldn't bend down because if you
bent down
you were next
he was like so you were literally just
you would look down and see faces of
people looking up at you and you could
not reach down to elbow
crazy right have you because i know how
many concerts you've been to dude you've
been to
and you were in you went to 70s arena
rock right yeah
can you ever ima can you ever remember
anything like that i told you
i told mike i love music i love
everything about it you know uh
i don't like this [__] now because you
got to show up with a vaccine card and
[__]
but that's a complete different [__]
story i went to the ted nugent aerosmith
poco
frank marino mahogany rush i mean it was
just a lineup and a half
it was like one of those one o'clock
shows that you're still there at 5 30.
and at five we looked at each other
harold smith was so [__] bad
hey where
is this this is 78 this is the summer of
78. oh they were [__] up though yeah
they were on their way down uh done with
mirrors
hadn't been out yet but they were done
and joe perry smashed his guitar and
stuff i went there to see ted nero smith
frank mourinho stole the [__] took the
oxygen out of my lungs
like frank mourinho took the took
everything out of my lungs like i
couldn't even [__] wait it was hot it
was humid
people were sweating there weren't no
water bottles back then nobody had water
bottles nobody had canteens nobody even
cared about hydration
you know and i remember being there and
like just going we got to get the [__]
out of here
there was a lot of dirty white people
people you know like doing all that
grateful dead [__] yeah i didn't even
know the grateful dead were
at that time i think i did but you know
i wasn't into him and i was like i'm i'm
we had a great time i remember walking
home
and finally getting to north bergen out
of sea caucus we had been walking for
about 45 minutes and you could hear
ted's solos
just in the air like loud like holy [__]
we're walking on the turnpike
and you could actually hear ted nugent's
we stayed for maybe four to 10 songs and
then we left but
i didn't like it
it was too long
it was a whole day i was suntanned i was
hungry
i just wanted to go home and i could see
that not that one there was it was fine
there it was fine up to the part i left
i left at like 5 30. i was there from
like 12. we started we got a ride out
there we had to walk home
i just didn't like the amount of people
and i just thought i wasn't ever going
to do that again
so i've never been to i've never gone to
a lollapalooza i never went to a u.s
festival i never went to the us open i i
never did odds fest i just don't need to
stand for seven [__] hours you know
i got a one and a half hour [__]
tolerance led zeppelin maybe two
if they do trampled underfoot
but uh
yeah you know
i just don't and i and i this this this
bothered me a little bit because i saw
houston and right away i thought about
skank fest yeah
so i thought about skank fest ari jimmy
rich voss all my friends are there miss
pat
and then i saw it was this astro world
what's the guy's name travis scott
travis scott yeah i've never heard of
this guy before
that's jacob's guy travis scott
travis scott and j cole that's jakey's
those are the hip-hop guys for jake okay
they i think he's did something or
whatever i don't know i've never heard
of him you know yeah it doesn't mean
[__] i'm a [__] old fogey so i don't
know anything about young music
but i don't think they're doing the
right things at these concerts
you know if you notice everything's
coming to a head movie sets
you know everybody's looking at rust
as this problem the problem was early
with that [__]
marky wahlberg kevin hart movie they did
in hollywood
some guy [__] died on there or
whatever
you know these concerts that everything
is getting bigger
yeah everything is getting bigger every
time but he's trying to make money
everybody's trying to make the money
they lost last year i don't know what it
is and i don't know what's making all
these people want to come out to these
things i mean you know 60 000 70 000
people
with just an ac for not tool but who was
it
it wasn't tool somebody else came and
did uh like the whole weekend
the [__] you couldn't even get a
hotel in atlantic city and they showed
pictures of them i forgot what the guy's
name are the band
you know and they're all there i mean
we're in the middle of [__] covert i
mean the numbers are down nobody gives a
[__]
but
you know you just have too many people
something's gonna happen
yeah it's like we were talking about
when you gamble when you gamble two days
a week you got a better chance than
gambling seven days a week the more
spaghetti you throw up on the wall it's
gonna stick eventually
you know with these concerts i like
little things man like i went to see the
last concert i went to was guns and
roses at the
on sunset
and
vine a little down yeah a little club
there
but i don't know what it's called that
was 1700 people
the palladium the palladium yeah
and then i went somewhere in beverly
hills to like a little theater and i saw
pat bennett's heart
and it was great in a little [__]
theater and i liked where i saw guns and
roses i don't mind paying the extra
yardstick
i agree i don't mind for a little bit
more intimate
setting you know i got this thing here
the pack center or whatever up here it's
supposed to be very nice it's like uh
the place in colorado
um
not not
red rocks but the other one
you know i i feel the same way
i i personally enjoy the music
and i enjoy the performance
of stand-ups and musicians more in
smaller places i hate seeing stand up i
don't want to go to the arena and see
anybody i don't think by the way i don't
think it's good for comedy i don't think
it's good for comedy but
i think everybody is a better comic in a
club
i think the energy's better or a smaller
theater do you know what i mean but that
energy and your interaction but as soon
as i'm in an arena watching my comedy on
a giant screen i i don't think it's as
good i think you lose
something it's and even like a big
theater you lose
yeah that intimacy i listen i i love
watching stand up with a brick behind
there yeah a brick wall and a microphone
and there's bottled water i don't need
much you know i don't need much to i
like
you know i like smaller venues you know
the reason why i put you on here today
i'm getting a lot of uh emails about
your new special i'm going to
congratulate you oh thank you man your
new special on youtube i'm just really
proud of you man because
you're doing it if i was doing comedy
right now i'd be doing how you're doing
it
very compact very small
you know what our mistake was
i'm gonna write a book about stand-up
comedy after i finish this book
i've been making a lot of notes at night
of things i would do differently
let me tell you what's the thing i would
do differently if i got a chance to do
it again
yeah i would have never gone to la
i've been thinking about it i was never
ever gonna go to la that was my [__]
number one rule when i got into comedy
i am not gonna go that way my uncle's
there i hate l.a i [__] always hated
i had been there 10 times
and i didn't think
i just over the years on the triple runs
i spoke to all those mediocre comics
good guys they just
went out there unprepared or whatever
they just they never fell in they never
got on the line they never got on the
conveyor belt
la beats you up
very roughly it didn't beat us up very
roughly we had lump you know we had
peaks and valleys there
but la has beat up some people you and i
have both watched how many people left
with that tail
between their legs
i think that how they treat stand-ups
and [__] like that i think it's not
healthy
i loved it i loved banging listen i got
no regrets about my career
i loved that those people when i was
doing comedy the 10-year mark told me i
was never going to be any good and those
same people had to come suck my dick at
the 22 year mark and i'm looking at them
taking that check and laughing patting
them on the side like it's going to be
okay
you had to bite your own tongue you had
to suck my dick even though you didn't
like me but now
so i felt bad for those people yeah
but i would have just become a
powerhouse comic
i wouldn't have worried about think
about korea if we didn't worry about
movies
tv
and everything else i like the podcast
angle of it
i really enjoy the podcast angle of it
i'm happy that this
uh avenue grew
i'm happy that this really blew up out
of proportion
i don't give a [__] about what people
say there's too many podcasts there's
never enough podcasters because there's
enough ears for all of us i'm not mad at
anybody for podcasting but i wouldn't
have gone to l.a josh wolf yeah
i think i would have stayed in a really
good right now
every city is a good comedy city
every city is great
boise
see well i don't know what's going on in
seattle people marching up there i don't
know what's going on in portland i don't
know what's going on in l.a but i know
arizona's tight
austin is tight
houston's tight
boston's tight new york is tight
all these little pockets are big you
don't have to go to la no more for all
you young comics watching
you could go to new york get tons of
stage time and they're going to come to
you when they come to you
you know people ask me a lot
i'm sure they do too about advice for
stand up
and it's really simple
get on stage and if you're if you're in
a place where you can't get on stage you
need to move to a place where you can
get on stage that's it it doesn't have
to be la anymore it doesn't even have to
be in new york anymore but i would tell
you this
if you're only getting on stage two or
three times a week
then give up
then if you're starting
and you're getting on stage two times a
week and the people who are already
successful are getting on stage three
times more than you i tell people like
if you're not then you you're already
going back just move to a place where
you can get on stage and do man do you
still have your notebook about all the
sets you did
you should show people
you want guys you want to know what work
is
you want to work i marveled at your you
you wrote down what jokes you did
like how it went
but meticulously and so
this is the type of when you say i'm
glad i put the work in you got to put
you've got to put every brick in the
pyramid you're going to you can't skip a
brick and there are just some paths you
need to take and one of those paths is
if you say i can't get on stage because
you've already lost
if you're like i can't you know what i
can't do three times a week because i
got a job well then you should do that
job
because what it takes to get to where
you are
is the work that you put in do you know
what i'm saying so like when people ask
all the time
what should i do how do i write get on
stage that once you're on stage you'll
figure it out everything else falls into
place everything else
and you talk to people who are going
through what you're going through i mean
it's such a beautiful
life in the beginning like all these
people looking to help you when you're
teaming up with people and you're
writing and you're smoking dope and
you're doing all this with five dollars
in your pocket yeah there's no
lamborghinis there's no [__]
grandioso computers there's no [__] p
you know you're just doing this and
you're loving it you're loving that
you're broke
it's great to be broke and go where am i
going to eat lunch today i don't know
let's play the cards and i'll send you
an exciting treat and you find the
subway sandwich on the floor you know
it's a [__] trip you're like oh [__]
i'm eating okay i could save my 82 cents
that i have in my pocket for tonight i
got to get another 17 so i could eat my
[__] wendy's that's what i ate every
day when i first moved to la it was the
99 cents burger the cup of chili and the
wendy's salad and then i go to your
house get a little turkey salad oh yeah
i still owe you 2 000 for the peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches [__]
blake was talking to me about your
peanut butter and jelly company
the other day blake called me for
something from caa we were talking
because i still remember you and josh
walked to the building with the peanut
butter i'd be holding jacob you'd be
holding a box of peanut butter jelly
and then you'd always go i was short one
peanut butter and jelly sandwich
and you look over at me like i knew it
was you
i know for a fact everybody was robbing
josh wolfe then josh couldn't turn
around
me his wife his brother
i remember his brother used to work in
compton and [__] and they used to charge
us for local phone calls josh would be
pulling his hands out of my head who
keeps calling compton who keeps calling
comments i don't know black people i
don't need black people you remember
yeah jonathan was going i don't know
anybody in compton jesus christ you just
showed up with an african-american you
know somebody in [__] compton
you teach a crenshaw dude he's like yeah
i don't know i don't know i don't know
anybody
somebody's calling crenshaw i was
stealing you you whose
god
[Music]
today i live a decent man okay i'm a
very decent man
but
a bottle of you who i pay for i can i'm
taking that [__]
i [__] went to a place last week that
they had you who's in a can off the nine
i was [__] starving and i was coming
back
from like somewhere and i was like i
can't take this no more i wanted this
was one of those broken down new jersey
bagel places
they only had like a half a raisin
cinnamon and [__] that's it they didn't
but the guy had i had to put a ham and
cheese on a [__]
onion bagel
not too good but it worked that day but
on the way out i saw that [__] i
had a yoohoo
in a can he had three of them the last
three because i can't find them anymore
yeah in the can
they taste different right they taste
different yeah they taste like the ones
at callahan's there's a place callahan's
up there and they have them on the on
the machine
oh
i'm tap
have you have you tapped back into
carvel at all since you've been back
home like a [__]
and my daughter
[__] loves it let me put this what
i've got let me be as honest as i can
with you okay
i got a
a regular one owned by chinese people
on the 516 on the 520. they
she doesn't make ice cream sodas or
shakes that it's a new modern carvel
okay not bad
then there's one on the 79
that's pretty [__] good
chinese people
and then there's one in cheesequake
where i go to jiu jitsu
oh
oh she's owned it for 30 years
she's got to be 300 pounds
and she works it in the daytime
so she knows how to make everything
[__] perfect
thin shakes
ice cream sodas
so i go when i go to jiu jitsu that's my
deal if i go to jiu jitsu and i work
hard
on my private i stop at carvel on the
way home
and i get an ice cream soda with no ice
cream in it
and i buy a box
of sundaes from my daughter so right now
in that freezer in the garage
there's a box of sundae sprinkled
and i have uh maybe a whole thing of uh
flying saucers
that's the one chocolate ones vanilla
ones i got plain and with colored and
chocolate sprinkles
and you know what look i've lost the
weight but i still do one caravel a week
listen i'm gonna tell you first of all
when i was growing up anybody who had a
freezer in their garage was rich
if you had a refrigerator in the garage
or a freezer where you had extra [__]
that meant you had that's i for to me
that was that meant the the pinnacle of
opulence do you know what i mean you're
like you got so much [__]
no this is a little box refrigerator
oh yeah somebody gave this to me in l.a
uh my neighbor gave this to me
and
we have a couple things like we have
steaks and [__] in there like it's just
meat that
i saw this morning pulling ground beef
yeah [__] meatloaf tonight um dude i
want to but i didn't say thank you about
the
special and thank you so much just so
you know man like right now
i'm having
i just every time i get on stage
all i focus on is having a good time
i'm like i just want to make sure i want
to i'm having fun and if i'm having fun
having a good time
they're going to have fun and have a
good time and and this special
yo the way i shot it this is the most me
i've ever done but the way i shot it i
shot it you know that middle camera when
you shoot is stationary on sticks
i had mine move just a little bit
because i wanted you to feel like you
were in the club
so it moves a little and i left every
mistake every hiccup i start jokes over
if i make a mistake my bad i wanted you
to feel like you were in the club with
me so it doesn't feel like effect i
wanted it to feel like a live experience
and then you know you shoot too much
right because then you take out
but then i was like wait a second
this is my special this is on youtube
this is my channel i'm gonna leave the
whole thing in you can start and stop
fast forward if you want but [__] it why
am i editing my own [__]
i edited things that were terrible but i
let it breathe so i let you feel like
you were there yo when i read the
comments and i'm not lying to you dude
i haven't and i don't usually read
comments on youtube not one bad not one
bad comment in that comment section
it's it's been amazed it's the best
thing that i've ever done without a
doubt i'm really proud of you i'm really
proud that
you uh
didn't
you did this all yourself no more l.a
no more agents telling you oh that's not
gonna work my friend did [__] you yeah
[__] you if you knew anything you'd be
doing this
so until you do this shut your [__]
mouth
that's what i put together about agents
now all of them could just shut their
[__] mouth
they know dick they give you the worst
advice in the world the best advice
anybody can give you josh wolf gave it
to you get on stage to your ass grows
roots shut your mouth repeat rinse and
do again tomorrow it's that easy call me
when you got 45 until then shut the [__]
up i don't give a [__] well i joe rogan
said i should be in the theater you
belong in montana in the witness
relocation [__] theater where nobody
will see you okay that's where you
[__] belong the same way i did
[__] comedy for the first 10 years so
nobody would [__] see you so you
would grant them that you know what i'm
saying so if the next born wouldn't be
[__] you know i don't want nobody to
[__] see me so everybody wants to be
seen in the third year congratulations
brother i love you
and i love you and thank you so much and
i owe you one one apology
um and i know you're gonna tell me i
don't but for me this is just where i am
in my life
you know what i la had kind of turned me
into somebody
that i just didn't now that i'm here
that i didn't like man
and those last three four years i don't
i don't really feel like i was a great
friend to anybody
and so if if i'm sure i had missteps or
you know i want to apologize for if
there were any time there where i
i wasn't the best friend i just got
caught up
i got caught up in a way
me as a person
i
never thought i never thought i would be
worried about what other people were
doing
i i was meddling in other people's lives
so much about what they had what i
didn't have
why he wasn't my friend and why i
couldn't be on his show
that it was weak it was weak and i was
living from a point in a place of
weakness about what wondering why i
didn't have things
and why i couldn't do things instead of
just really being grateful to things
that i did have and the things that i
could do i have a great life great
family great friends great career what
am i complaining about do you know what
i mean and i feel like l.a
puts you in a corner to go beyond you
got this but look what all these other
people have and you're like [__] this
isn't good enough i need more you know
hey man we do comedy we don't worry
about the joneses we only worry about
one person us so
i love you stay in touch
good luck to you where are you at this
weekend
mohegan sub beautiful you're up in
connecticut up there yeah
five shows
uh
four shows saturday and friday already
sold out so they added thursday
beautiful
have a great weekend up there my friend
where can they find you
uh uh everything's josh wolfe comedy uh
go to my youtube channel i put all my
stuff up there for free
uh i put a new comedy bit up every week
i got joe i told you i think from here
on out maybe no more specials just 20
new minutes to stand up every three
months that's it that's perfect and they
could live off that and
youtube is paying
nobody else's best dude i love you
i love you man i'm so happy for you you
look more like happiness
yeah no no no it's uh
i learned
next time i'll call you and we'll
talk about my [__] uh lackluster
experiences in l.a that's gonna fuel
myself all right buddy love you just
love you stay black later
all right you bad [__] we're
back
i hope uh you enjoyed josh wolfe and i
little tate tate
we just talked about comedy and what's
going on with our lives and uh
what's happening
i want to thank josh wolfe for coming on
the show this week i want to thank you
guys
for always having my back you know uh
i went through a lot this year but i'm
feeling [__] tip-top magoo and part
of it is because of you guys for having
my back
chit chatting with me you know and
always having a good time i love you
guys with all my heart stay black do not
forget
laughing gas is stocked up over at the
ice cream shop and packwoods has merged
with us
and they're in stores all over [__]
california but we're getting licenses in
nevada
new jersey new york city they're all
coming so we'll have laughing gas and a
store near you
in time [__] thank you thank you
for watching the joint i'll see you
[__] uh
monday morning
tip top magoo on the 15th of the month i
love you have a great day and now for a
word for my [__] sponsor jack
all right i want to thank josh wolfe but
most importantly i want to thank you
guys for always having my back i hope
you enjoyed it real quick the joint is
sponsored by
better help online therapy listen after
the pandemic
it's all set us back a little bit
there's people who have pushed right
through it there's other people who have
problems listen there's nothing wrong
with you okay
if you're still scared of going to
therapy think about it this way you got
to change your all every 90 days to
prevent bigger issues down the road
therapy is the same thing for you but
it's for your brain going to therapy is
routine maintenance for your mental and
emotional wellness i never did i never
knew that and i wouldn't have gone even
if you told me because i was too much of
a [__] man to go talk to somebody but
that all changes here and betterhelp.com
was there for me they were tremendous my
counselor's name is dana she is great
uh going to therapy doesn't mean there's
something wrong with you man it just
means that you're investing time in
yourself to keep your mind healthy
better help is customized online therapy
they offer video phone and live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't want to and it's a lot
much more affordable than in person
therapy and you can start communicating
with your therapist in less than 48
hours so if you contact reach out to
them today you'll be on the phone with
your therapist by friday you have to
feel this way anymore why invest in
everything else and not in your mind
just for you joint listeners i'm going
to give you 10 off your first month so
you see the advantages of betterhelp.com
slash diaz again
go to betterhelp.com
fill out the uh information
press and code diaz i'm gonna give you
10 off your first month take control of
your life and help you you deserve with
better help okay
the joint is also brought to you by
c b d lion did i read this one already
no okay i just want to double check with
your [__] cbd line is the best
how do i know because they push me
through a surgery and a year of other
injuries from hamstrings to [__]
shoulder pain
to [__] insomnia cbd line or cover
you from all directions cbd helps you
sleep cbd helps with anxiety
the cbd gummies that they have are
tremendous the vapor pens are tremendous
the cream is tremendous the kinesiology
tape is tremendous and all you need is
just a little strip of it if you watch
monday night football this week you see
all those guys have the kinesiology tape
on the back of their arms and whatnot
this stuff works guys you don't know
where to get it
cbdlion.com go to cbdlion.com
read learn see all the products they
have and which products can help you the
best once you figure out
go to the bottom checkout and press
encode
diaz joint or church
to get twenty percent off okay delivered
right to your house why buy your get why
buy cbd at a gas station when you got
the best c b d lion again go to cbd lion
press and co joey church or joint and
get 20 off
delivered right to your [__]
house the joint is also brought to you
by draftkings sportsbooks this weekend
they're showing up with an unbelievable
offer to celebrate the greatest sport on
ice
nhl
florida's coming up to see the jersey
devils this week you want to be a part
of it why do i love draftkings as much
as i do i'll tell you why because
they're [__] tremendous
okay from the prop bets to the casino
to just everything that you could bet on
there from boxing
to ufc to college basketball they got
chinese ping pong listen they got it all
if two [__] roaches are gonna have a
race in elmwood park today they got the
line on draftkings it doesn't matter if
you're a one-time clapper or a death
deflection
however they like to lamp
you win
if sportsbook isn't available in your
state draftkings won't leave you
empty-handed everyone can play
huge cash prizes all season long
with the draftkings daily fantasy sports
contest draftkings has given all new
customers a free shot at millions of
dollars in total prizes with their first
deposit
draftkings are safe secure and reliable
i love them i use them all the time
most importantly you can withdraw your
cash whenever you want download the
draftking sportsbook app now today use
promo code joey let's get this week
started right throw down a dollar on any
nhl game and win 103 bets if either your
team scores a goal it's that easy
this week one puck hits the nets you're
getting your dick sucked with big money
because the draft king sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
nhl
using code joey you got to be 21 older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania colorado
tennessee connecticut new customers only
minimum five hour deposit with a dollar
wager one per customer don't get cute
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gambling problem call 1-800 gambler but
if not head to draftkings and let's win
some [__] gidas i want to thank
draftkings i want to thank cbd lion
i want to thank better health
i want to thank annette and i want to
thank bluechu
for having our backs this week but most
importantly i want to thank you [__]
savages for always being here and
supporting and showing up
no matter what uncle joey shows up i
love you [__] have a great week
stay black
i'll see you mondays the 15th tip top
magoo
[Music]
hmm
you